queridos amigos nos habéis pedido muchas
veces que hablemos mucho más de américa
latina pues bien ya tenemos una solución
la tan política
[Música]
una newsletter que hemos preparado junto
a la consultora cerx perspectives si te
suscribes cada mes podrás recibir 12
boletines con la mejor información y los
mejores análisis sobre américa latina
para que estéis al día y entendáis mejor
todo lo que ocurre en esta región y el
coste pues puedes suscribirte por menos
de 30 céntimos de euro por cada boletín
menos de un café a la semana a cambio
estarás al tanto de los principales
acontecimientos y cambios en américa
latina' y conocerás todas sus
implicaciones además todos los que nos
estáis apoyando en el nivel 4 y 5 de
patrián recibiréis la tan política a
coste cero tenéis toda la información en
latam político.com
[Aplausos]
[Música]
el 14 de febrero del año 2021 quien
fuera presidente de la argentina durante
dos mandatos carlos saúl menem falleció
a la edad de 90 años hablamos de una de
las figuras más controvertidas de la
política argentina no hay término medio
según con quien hablemos o bien lo eleva
los altares o bien lo demoniza
estoy muy triste porque fue el mejor
presidente que tuvimos y el mejor
gobernador fue una época muy mala para
todo el país económicamente nos vinimos
muy abajo
menem fue un político de raza uno de
esos líderes sociales a los que les
gusta estar rodeado de gente famosa como
deportistas artistas y modelos y que
tampoco tienen reparos a decir blanco y
luego hacer negro no se sabe cuánto
tiempo pasará y cuánta sangre se
derramará pero nuestro territorio
malvinas volverá al pueblo carlos saúl
menem 14 de febrero de 1989 un año antes
de retomar las relaciones con el reino
unido- una estrategia que de alguna
manera le cedió tanto para ganar
elecciones como para hacer enemigos
durante 10 años entre el 89 y el 99 fue
presidente de la república argentina y
queridos amigos amigas os puedo asegurar
que este fue un periodo realmente
intenso sus reformas de corte liberal y
las múltiples acusaciones de corrupción
dieron forma a una etapa que algunos han
calificado como el tiempo en el que la
argentina quiso cambiar
pero quién fue exactamente carlos saúl
menem como cambio argentina porque las
reformas que promovió no se sostuvieron
con el paso del tiempo realmente tuvo un
plan para frenar la fatal tendencia al
colapso que la argentina lleva
transitando desde hace más de 70 años
pues atentos
y semblante de caudillo
carlos menen nació en anillaco un
pequeño pueblecito de la provincia
argentina de la rioja el día 2 de julio
de 1930 hijo de inmigrantes sirios
cuando siria aún pertenecía al imperio
turco durante toda su vida fue conocido
precisamente como el turco
menem desde muy joven tuvo una clara
inclinación por la política militando en
el movimiento peronista movimiento que
pasó a estar prohibido tras la caída de
juan domingo perón en el 55
sin embargo al retornar la democracia en
1973 junto al regreso de perón a la
presidencia menem fue elegido como
gobernador de la rioja cargo que ocupó
hasta el 24 de marzo de 1976 día en el
que se produjo un nuevo golpe militar a
partir de ese momento a carlos menen
nuestro protagonista como le ocurre
otros tantos le tocó deambular de
prisión en prisión un tema como veremos
espinoso porque una de las medidas más
polémicas y que más él ha criticado de
cuando fue presidente fue precisamente
la de indultar a los jefes militares de
la dictadura lo que muchos desconocen es
que él mismo fue víctima de esa
dictadura
[Música]
pero no nos adelantemos
tras la vuelta de la democracia en el
año 83 menem volvió a ser elegido de
nuevo gobernador de la rioja cargo en el
que se mantuvo hasta el 89 cuando
renunció para ocupar el sillón
presidencial en ese momento en la década
de los 80
menem era visto como un personaje
extraño cuando todavía no estaba tan de
moda el término popular
menem ya era populista se reivindicaba
como un nacionalista empedernido
reclamaba la recuperación de las
malvinas y defendía la lucha contra el
imperialismo incluso su imagen se
asimilaba a la de un caudillo riojano de
1829 facundo quiroga
claro que a medida que se iba
introduciendo las altas esferas del
poder nacional
esas exageradas patillas fueron poco a
poco disminuyendo hasta desaparecer por
completo amigos amigas podéis creerme si
os digo que el giro que carlos saúl
menem bío como presidente aún causa
perplejidad atentos
[Música]
desde el mene móvil
en el 88 la etapa del presidente raúl
alfonsín llegaba a su final tras un
complicado y convulso mandato
caracterizado por la amenaza de
alzamientos militares el enfrentamiento
con los sindicatos peronistas una mala
situación económica e incluso en los
últimos años la hiperinflación todo
parece indicar que el próximo presidente
sería del principal partido de la
oposición el partido peronista así que
la disputa la gran disputa electoral se
produjo precisamente en el seno de este
partido para hacerse con la candidatura
inicialmente el gran favorito era
antonio cafiero un tipo que apenas un
año antes en 1967 había ganado la
gobernación de la provincia de buenos
aires la más rica y poblada del país sin
embargo amigos en esta ocasión por
primera y única vez en la historia del
partido peronista se realizaron
elecciones internas primarias para
escoger al candidato a las
presidenciales del 89 y queridos amigos
saltó la sorpresa contra todo pronóstico
menem derrotó a su contrincante por más
cien mil votos amigos había nacido una
nueva era la era de los menemistas
[Música]
desde ese momento nuestro protagonista
comenzó a recorrer cada rincón del país
a bordo del menem móvil un autobús desde
el cual menem no dejó de repetir una y
otra vez su emblemático eslogan de
campaña síganme no los voy a defraudar
[Aplausos]
durante la campaña ha prometido todo
tipo de cosas lanzar una revolución
productiva subidas generales de los
salarios o incluso recuperar las
malvinas a sangre y fuego quien se iba a
resistir a esta nueva ola de ilusión voy
a gobernar por los niños pobres que
tienen hambre y por los niños ricos que
tienen tristeza carlos saúl menem sólo
puedo ofrecerle a mi polo sacrificio
trabajo y esperanza solo puedo
asegurarle que será el primer argentino
a la hora de la austeridad de poner el
hombro de apretar los dientes del
esfuerzo
carlos saúl menem aunque no fueron pocos
quienes auguraron que con semejante
populista al frente argentina terminaría
pareciéndose más a cuba que a cualquier
otro país estaba claro que en ese
momento nadie podía imaginarse el gran
viraje que este político iba a
protagonizar pero así es como se alzó
con la presidencia
[Música]
atentos a este último candidato álvaro
alsogaray de la unión de centro
democrático cuando menem dio su golpe de
timón se convirtió en uno de sus
principales asesores entonces cuando uno
lo vea socialista como mi teherán o
felipe gonzález enseñar marchar
prácticamente en sentido contrario de lo
que dice doctrinaria ideológicamente el
socialismo llega a la conclusión de que
nosotros estamos en el camino correcto
el golpe de timón
en el 89 la llegada de media mala casa
rosada no fue precisamente en camino de
rosas la situación económica en ese
momento era caótica lo que bueno
tratándose de la argentina tampoco creo
que sea una gran sorpresa
el caso es que sus primeros meses no
fueron muy diferentes a su predecesor en
1989 terminó con una inflación superior
al 3 mil por ciento y en 1990 superó el
2000 300 por ciento los primeros 20
meses de menen en el poder fueron tan
erráticos como lo había sido el gobierno
de su predecesor raúl alfonsín
[Música]
sin embargo un momento porque todo
cambió en 1991 cuando menem revolucionó
su gabinete nombrando como ministro de
economía al entonces ministro de
exteriores- domingo felipe cavallo a
partir de ese momento se comenzó a
aplicar de verdad la ley 23.696 de
reforma del estado que se había aprobado
en agosto del 89 nada más llegar al
poder pero que sin embargo se había
quedado en stand by de repente la
política económica del país y sobre todo
lo que había sido históricamente el
peronismo dio un giro de 180 grados que
nadie se llame a engaño la
transformación del estado la
privatización de empresas públicas la
eliminación de regulaciones el
saneamiento de sus cuentas fiscales la
apertura al mundo y la ausencia de
control es innecesario no constituyen un
mecanismo para ponerle una bandera de
remate a nuestro estado nacional todos
los contrarios
switch la crisis la hiperinflación y el
contexto internacional que se estaba
viviendo con la caída de la unión
soviética y el muro de berlín parecían
dejar claro que a la argentina no le
quedaba otra que cambiar de rumbo y eso
eso es exactamente lo que hizo en
nuestro protagonista de hoy carlos saúl
menem quien puso sobre la mesa un
concepto completamente nuevo en la
política argentina la economía popular
de mercado ahora bien en qué consistió
exactamente este giro pues digamos que
en poner al país patas arriba a
arremangarse la camisa y ponerse manos a
la obra para cambiarlo todo o como
veremos casi todo
el 27 de marzo de 1991 se aprobó la ley
23.928 de convertibilidad con la que se
creó una nueva moneda para sustituir el
austral el peso se eliminaron cuatro
ceros de tal forma que diez mil
australes pasaron a convertirse en un
peso que a su vez era convertibles por
un dólar es decir se establece una
paridad fija para ganarse la confianza
de los ahorradores y evitar la tentación
de darle a la máquina de imprimir
billetes el resultado es que los precios
comenzaron a estabilizarse y la
inflación regresó a un nivel terrenal
luego en octubre de ese mismo año de
1991 se aprobó el decreto de regulatorio
2.284 que liberalizó el comercio
anterior el comercio exterior impulsó
una reforma fiscal una reforma del
mercado de capitales y la transformación
del sistema de pensiones que pasó a ser
privados
[Música]
y eso no es todo al mismo tiempo que se
promovió la apertura económica el
gobierno lanzó un enorme plan de
privatizaciones durante el primer
mandato de emmen en el gobierno
argentino privatizó empresas públicas de
telecomunicaciones gas agua electricidad
ferrocarriles correos televisión radio
líneas aéreas e incluso producción de
armamento paradójicamente todas las
empresas que perón había estatizado
entre 1946 y 1949 fueron privatizadas
por menem entre 1992 y 1995 gracias al
respaldo mayoritario de los diputados y
senadores peronistas esa enorme ola de
privatización junto a todos los cambios
aprobados que hicieron que los capitales
extranjeros comenzaran a inundar el país
según datos del indec el instituto
nacional argentino de estadísticas y
censos la inversión extranjera directa
pasó de unos 16 mil millones en 1992 más
de 65 mil en 1999
para que os hagáis una idea la economía
argentina creció entre el 91 y el 94 a
un ritmo del 7 por ciento de repente la
prosperidad había llegado a un destino
que parecía imposible y con ella la
modernidad
fijaos por ejemplo en lo que ocurrió con
la industria de las telecomunicaciones
hasta ese momento la compañía pública de
teléfonos entel podía tardar décadas en
instalar una nueva línea en un domicilio
de hecho las casas que tenían un
teléfono llegaban a costar entre un 10 y
un 20% más que las que no lo tenían
porque era complicadísimo hacerse con
uno de locos y si estamos hablando de la
década de los 80 y los 90 no en 1910
pues bien la privatización de esta
actividad y la llegada de empresas
extranjeras como telefónica o telecom
italia alimentó una enorme explosión en
el sector instalar una nueva línea pasa
a ser cosa de unos pocos días llegó
también la comunicación móvil y el
incipiente internet exactamente lo mismo
que ocurrió con la electricidad si hasta
ese momento los apagones eran frecuentes
e incluso estaban programados por el
propio gobierno sin embargo con la
privatización los apagones se redujeron
un montón al tiempo que la tarifa de los
consumidores se redujo
en más de un 24% como os podéis imaginar
todos estos cambios y el crecimiento
económico que se estaba produciendo
mejoraron el nivel de vida de los
argentinos y de hecho la tasa de pobreza
pasó del 47,3 por ciento en el 89 a
menos de la mitad el 22,2 por ciento en
el 95
[Música]
[Aplausos]
pero los cambios nos limitaron
exclusivamente a la parte económica
durante este primer mandato de menem con
el objetivo de consolidar la democracia
impulsó también políticas como la de la
reconciliación nacional por la cual
indulto a todos los militares e
integrantes de grupos guerrilleros que
habían participado respectivamente en la
dictadura o en la sucesión de atentados
que el país vivió durante los años 70 y
[Música]
y amigos así con una argentina que
parecía empezar a comerse de nuevo el
mundo es como llegamos a la segunda
legislatura de este político
el pacto de los olivos
los primeros resultados del plan de
reformas hicieron que en las elecciones
parlamentarias del 93 que tenían que
renovar un tercio del senado y la mitad
de la cámara de diputados los candidatos
peronistas arrasaran el apoyo que
recibió men fue tan grande que por
primera y única vez en la historia el
peronismo ganó en la mismísima ciudad de
buenos aires
sin embargo había un problema en ese
momento la constitución argentina fijaba
un mandato presidencial de 6 años y
prohibía la reelección inmediata es
decir a pesar del triunfalismo y el
fervor popular menem no podía
presentarse a las siguientes elecciones
y cambiar la constitución no parecía una
tarea nada sencilla se necesitaba el
apoyo de dos tercios de cada cámara del
congreso y en ese momento la oposición
liderada por la unión cívica radical y
su líder el ex presidente raúl alfonsín
no estaban por la labor
y qué pensáis que hizo entonces el
presidente argentino pues ni más ni
menos que llevar a cabo una sorprendente
jugada política veis como sabía que en
la mayoría del electorado estaba a favor
de la reforma constitucional anunció una
consulta un plebiscito no vinculante
para decirle a la oposición vamos venga
decidido ahora que os oponéis a la
voluntad popular
menudo gambito de dama jaque mate
en 1994 carlos menem y raúl alfonsín
firmaron el pacto de los olivos que
habilitó la reforma constitucional que
le permitiría presentarse a la
reelección al tiempo que se actualizó el
sistema de elección cada mandato pasó de
6 a 4 años y se eliminó el colegio
electoral para establecer la elección
directa en segunda vuelta
y así es como en 1995 menem fue
reelegido por una enorme mayoría simple
y llanamente arrasó en las elecciones
sin embargo este nuevo mandato no iba a
resultar tan exitoso como el primero
atentos
deuda estancamiento y pobreza
todo parecía ir como la seda había
estabilidad monetaria una inflación
cercana al 0% y la creciente en libertad
comercial había abierto a los argentinos
todos los productos del gran almacén que
es el mundo argentina aparecía de vuelta
a la primera línea del éxito
internacional y el presidente rodeado de
actrices artistas y deportistas parecía
toda una estrella del rock sin embargo
un momento no habrá es aún la botella de
champán a pesar de todos los cambios
hubo una cosa que nunca se corrigió el
gasto público y el enorme tamaño del
estado argentino que no dejó de crecer
[Música]
durante unos años los ingresos de las
privatizaciones pagaron buena parte de
las facturas pero luego el gobierno
argentino fue incrementando más y más su
deuda exterior para que os hagáis una
idea cuando menem llegó al poder
argentina tenía una deuda de 63 mil
millones de dólares cuando se marchó y a
pesar de todos los ingresos recibidos
por las privatizaciones y el crecimiento
económico la deuda pública tendría ya
123 mil millones de dólares los mercados
internacionales habían confiado en la
argentina pero una vez más el país había
excedido
además el tipo de cambio fijo con el
dólar mantenía el peso sobrevalorado lo
que a corto plazo fue para las empresas
argentinas que aún tenían que hacer
frente a muchas rigideces laborales un
esfuerzo adicional que complicó su
competitividad internacional lo que
forzó una reestructuración productiva
que afectó sobremanera a la industria
el sistema tenía un grave problema de
sostenibilidad por un lado el estado no
paraba de gastar sin poder recurrir al
banco central por el otro mantener la
convertibilidad 1 a 1 con el dólar era
algo que se conseguía apoyando el peso
lo que consumía dólares que había que
financiar con más emisiones de deuda
externa y para colmo el tipo de cambio
uno a uno estaba provocando reajustes
justo en los sectores económicos que
tenían que proporcionar los dólares
suponía menos dólares y más paro y
entonces más gasto público y vuelta a
empezar el resultado un enorme castillo
de naipes el motivo pues que uno el
estado no quiso apretarse el cinturón'
segundo no se atrevió a tocar la
convertibilidad por miedo a una enorme
fuga de capitales y tercero tampoco
quiso meterse de lleno en la regulación
laboral y claro quizás la economía
argentina habría funcionado con una o
dos de estas decisiones pero no con
todas el paro que venció la deuda se
disparó la pobreza repuntó y las
finanzas argentinas comenzaron a irse a
pique
[Música]
por si fuera poco los gobiernos de menem
estuvieron también empañados con muchas
sombras de corrupción las
privatizaciones se habían llevado a cabo
pero la posterior liberalización de los
diferentes sectores no se ejecutó
completamente quizás porque los
incentivos apuntaban en otra dirección
había muchas sospechas de corrupción él
yomagate el contrabando de armas los
casos de sobres un no parar mientras las
cosas marchaban la sociedad miró para
otro lado pero cuando empezaron a no ir
bien entonces su popularidad empezó a
resentirse cuando se acercó el fin de su
segundo importante último mandato y
quiso volver a maniobrar para
presentarse esta vez ya no lo consiguió
de hecho en las elecciones del 99 fue la
oposición quien se llevó el gato al
agua' quien ganó la batalla pero la
situación volvió a ser tan problemática
que en el 2001 se produjo una corrida
contra el peso que desembocó en el
colapso del 2001 en el famoso corralito
[Música]
de repente en el país donde casi todo el
mundo había sido forofo de menem pareció
que nunca nadie lo hubiera apoyado fue
el caso sin ir más lejos del matrimonio
de los kirchner a pesar de todo menem lo
volvió a intentar en 2003 y ojo fue el
candidato más votado en primera vuelta
sin embargo sin opciones de cara la
segunda vuelta que le enfrentaba a
néstor kirchner se partía con muchos más
apoyos decidió tirar la toalla que
kirchner se quede con su 22% yo me quedo
con mi pueblo gane la primera vuelta y
me voy carlos saúl menem amigos menem ha
sido uno de los políticos más
carismáticos de la historia a pesar de
llegar al poder en una situación muy
difícil hiperinflación incluida su
primer mandato fue casi para embarcar y
por primera vez en décadas volvió a
despertar el sueño argentino sin embargo
la complacencia y el no completar los
deberes hizo que ese sueño terminara por
estallar en una violenta explosión que
acabó condenando todas las reformas
desde entonces el ex presidente se pasó
una gran parte de su vida en los
tribunales y si no entro en la cárcel
fue por su inmunidad
senador cargo que ostentó hasta su
último día pero llegó hasta aquí turno
para ti cómo valoras la presidencia de
carlos saúl menem en qué crees que falló
perseguía un plan claro y predeterminado
o las reformas fueron simplemente una
forma de ganar tiempo necesita que es
argentina un nuevo menem como el de
principios de los 90 déjanos por aquí
abajo tus comentarios ya sabes si este
vídeo te ha resultado interesante
no olvides darle al botón de like y
suscríbete a visar politics si aún no lo
has hecho un saludo y hasta la próxima
no creo que ningún país en la tierra
sustente los mismos principios y los
mismos conceptos después de 50 años